(mysterious music)
- The war took a lot from this place.
We all started from this wilderness,
and it has to remain on us
otherwise we lost our
identity, we lost part of us.
(intense music)
I am part of the next generation of women
that has to make sure
that this place survives.
(intense music)
- It's difficult to explain to somebody
who did not know what was here,
but myself, I knew what was here.
(urgent music)
We are in Gorongosa National
Park in Southern Africa.
Very close to the Indian Ocean.
Tourists, they used to come
from all over the world,
and animal populations used to be huge.
War in Mozambique was very terrible.
One million people died.
When a country faces war, nature
is first to face challenge.
Animals have been poached to buy firearms
and equipment to feed soldiers.
90% of animal population disappeared.
Our mission of this park is to restore
the Gorongosa ecosystem.
Not only nature but also
to develop human beings.
- As a woman, especially
in the science field,
in the beginning it was really bad.
I remember very well my
first time in the field
and the rangers would say,
no I'm not going with you to the field
because you're a woman, you're
a girl, you won't make it.
I've been tracking these
elephants for two months so far.
So it's quite recent.
I can't see footprints
but it's very fresh.
There's not even dung beetles in it yet.
They went into the forest.
There's other women extremely brave
that do patrols every day, the rangers.
Take one!
(foreign language conversation)
I became a ranger because I wanted
to work and move ahead with my life.
Some of the training
was difficult for women,
but I wanted the job.
I pushed through and realized
I could do anything a man could do.
Before I came here there
were many poachers.
The animal population used to suffer a lot
because of the steel wires and traps.
We find them and remove them.
We are protecting all the animals
that are here at Gorongosa National Park.
You know she works with a very big animal.
Which animal is really, really big?
Elephants!
- What would happen to us
if girls are not educated?
What will this world be?
I mean.
Who wants to work with elephants?
Raise your hands.
So you should have many
questions for her today!
- The girls club is a platform
where girls can talk
and share their ideas,
share their challenges.
I didn't have a very smooth childhood.
Not because my parents were not good, no.
On the contrary it was just,
we were poor and we had
many, many difficulties.
It's just what many other African girls
are also going through.
I'm from Beira.
I grew up there. I studied there.
But it wasn't easy.
No one paid for me. I couldn't
even buy the school uniform.
I used teeny tiny pencils.
There are lots of challenges.
But the most important
thing is not to quit.
I never gave up.
(singing in foreign language)
It's important to remind them
that there's another door for them.
That they can be something.
They can break that
circle and they can fly.
(laughs) Yeah.
(in foreign language)
(children clapping)
(Dominique laughs)
It's important to do
something in my country
because otherwise who will?
(dramatic music)
Do you see?
They've just gone into the forest.
(gasps)
We have ellies.
Don't charge, be nice.
That's a nice bull.
Yeah, it's gonna go to the water.
It's okay.
Here they are. Hi.
Look at that one resting
the trunk on the others,
on the younger, you see that?
The biggest thing that connects me
with elephants is their empathy.
They do anything to protect their family.
They're capable to
forgive even when humans
have done so many bad things to them.
The elephant population is recovering,
we're seeing an increase in the numbers
and I am seeing a lot of
new babies being born.
Gorongosa is growing and is thriving.
The park has a new vision and a new model.
(Radio chatter)
Some of our initiatives
are already being taken
and adapted to other parks in Mozambique.
So yes, Gorongosa can act as
a role model for other places.
People need nature.
And people must take care of nature.
Gorongosa don't cry.
We are going to plant what is needed here.
We are taking care of you.
People are now looking and
feeling connected again
with nature because of
Gorongosa, especially for girls.
They want to be biologists.
They want to be conservationists.
Now we have women rangers
for our communities,
from the buffer zone.
It is a gate, you know,
for all these women.
They're seeing this chance
and they're taking it.
(upbeat music)